mes chers compatriotes etlire président
de la République est un acte très
sérieux et qui va conditionner notre vie
non pas pendant quelques semaines ou
quelques
mois mais pendant C ans c temps pendant
lesquels les épreuves ne nous seront
certainement pas compté pendant lesquel
nous devons
affirmer notre volonté et nous donner
les moyens d'améliorer le bien-être des
Français et aussi la grandeur de la
France ce n'est donc pas un geste
d'humeur c'est un geste de
réflexion le 24 avril dernier vous vous
êtes prononcé un tiers ont approuvé la
démarche de du candidat du Parti
socialiste 36 %
ont soutenu l'action de redressement et
approuveré le projet de ma MAJ
mon
gouverement et lui ont apporté ses voix
mais
30% ce qui est beaucoup on marqué en
votant pour d'autres leur mécontentement
ou leurs
inquiétudes je les ai
compris il y a dans les perspective qui
s'ouvre des préoccupations qui sont
prioritaires mais je voudrais vous
demander
qui entre le candidat socialiste et moi
est le mieux à même d'y répondre le
chômage pendant 5 ans les socialistes
l'ont laissé augmenter
considérablement depuis 2 ans je l'ai
stabilisé et j'ai amorcé sa diminution
notamment pour les jeunes la protection
sociale le candidat socialiste a remis
en cause les intérêts chômeurs notamment
de longue durée ou les droits des
prèretraités j'ai redressé la situation
financière de la sécurité sociale et je
suis en mesure aujourd'hui non seulement
d'assurer l'équilibre pour ce qui
concerne les retraites mais également de
prévoir une nouvelle conquête sociale
c'est-à-dire le droit pour tous d'avoir
une activité minimum garanti rémunéré et
comportant la protection sociale la
sécurité
nai pas besoin de développer la
situation laissée par les socialistes et
le redressement amorcé par mon
gouvernement il en va de même pour
l'identité culturelle la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine ou pour
l'éducation et la formation ou après une
période de diminution des
moyens nous avons engagé l'effort
nécessaire et l'ouverture vers la vie
économique de notre système d'éducation
et de formation je pourrais multiplier
les
exemples on ne peut pas se prononcer
simplement sur des mots sur le flou d'un
propos qui veut tromper tout le monde il
faut aussi juger à partir de ce qui a
été fait et donc des compétences de la
capacité de chacun à répondre aux
difficultés du temps
présent demain il faudra gouverner et
vite nous n'avons on pas de temps à
perdre si le candidat socialiste était
élu il n'a pas de
majorité il faudrait dissoudre
l'Assemblée entrer dans une nouvelle
période de consultation nationale pour
élire les députés dans des conditions
qui on le voit bien aujourd'hui risquent
de conduire à certaines formme
d'aventure et en tous les cas de fortes
incertitude et de des pouvoirs
publics j'ai une
majorité je peux nommer un gouvernement
et engager immédiatement dès le
lendemain de
l'élection la politique de redressement
qui
s'impose pour faire demain de notre pays
une France plus juste plus solidaire
plus généreuse à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur une France mieux à même
d'être entendue dans le monde et
d'assumer sa grandeur qui fait partie de
son histoire et de notre ambition c'est
pourquoi je vous demande de réfléchir à
deux fois avant de vous exprimer avant
de
décider dimanche prochain et d'apporter
votre suffrage à ceux qui dans des
conditions difficiles pendant 2 ans ont
amorcé le redressement de notre
pays